foreign
let's go to Elizabeth in Dallas Texas
what's up Elizabeth
hey Dr deloney thanks for taking my call
you got it you doing well
I'm well how about you very very good
very very good what's up
so I have sort of an embarrassing silly
problem but hey hold on hold on hold on
hold on have you met me
that's true
whatever you're about to say you're good
you are good okay there's just a few
million people listening you are you are
just between us don't worry about it
there you go all right so what's up
The Familiar space
um after dark by myself essentially like
so hotels Airbnb like it can even be a
friend's house like
um so like spending the night somewhere
like I can do it like in a hotel I don't
love it but I can like force myself
um but like an actual house or something
with more entry points no forget it okay
so number one this isn't silly or weird
it's not common but it's not weird Okay
um if you if you've listened to the show
for any length of time you'll know I'll
ask like pulling the thread on this this
is your body telling you you're not safe
where does that where does that come
from
well
so I kind of feel like like like a
little kid in this fear because I feel
like I've always had it like you do when
you're a kid you're afraid of the dark
you're afraid to be alone and I never
outgrew it but then
um I'm sure obviously you saw the notes
but several years ago like 15 16 years
ago
um I had a break-in in my house and was
attacked by
um a convicted rapist essentially which
Elizabeth lead with that
like the issue with already there and I
guess that just compounded it but I feel
like it doesn't bother me like I don't
think about it like I could go take a
jog outside at night but if you put me
inside of a house that's when the fears
come and that's where like the
irrational like you know that I check
all the doors or you know can you get in
that window you know whatever sure
um did your folks do that
no not at all okay like we grew up in
the country I doubt the door was even
locked half the time and that's
also the ironic thing like I could
forget to lock my own door and in a way
that kind of makes me feel better
because I know like
um it's not so
ingrained I guess you know like my own
drawer would be I mean I might in the
morning be like whoops forgot that you
know and I shouldn't have done that but
it's not so much like in my own space
but if you were to like go out of town
and you would say hey can you watch my
dogs or whatever I would gladly do so
but then like if it involves going to
your house at night forget it like even
if it's just go in your house for 10
minutes like I would have a panic attack
and forget it no I'd be out like so is
this something that you want to be
different or is this something that
you're willing to just make peace with
and there's not a right or wrong answer
to this
like for it to be different because I
would like to be able to
um
I won't say I don't dread trips or
things like that but
like I'm potentially taking a job that's
going to require travel which is fine
that's great but I would like to not
feel like I'm sleeping with one eye open
or you got it you got it
so I um
I'm writing a note here
so
for some reason and I don't even think
it matters why this is just I don't I
don't I don't think it matters your body
has identified
unfamiliar places at night as a no-go
not safe okay it's put a GPS pin in that
and every time you find yourself in that
situation or leaning towards that
situation it sounds your alarms right
and
because we're people and we have giant
frontal lobes
we can spin our bodies up even thinking
about going to a house at night right
and I bet you could tell me a story in
about three minutes and your heart would
start racing really fast just thinking
about it oh yeah that's that's what a
great gift we have right we don't even
have to have to do the scary thing we
can just think about it and make
ourselves nuts
so here's the the good news is you can
go through your life and just kind of
make your way around it and that's fine
right and that's that's essentially what
I've done like I just avoid those
situations or you can heal from this and
I've got good news and bad news good
news is you can totally heal from this
bad news is there's one way to heal and
it is directly through the middle of
this I knew you were gonna say that
that's the only way and so
your brain your your thinking brain has
made peace this happened I went to
counseling from the break-in from the um
the the near traumatic rape like I made
peace of that I'm not even I don't even
when I think about it my heart rate
doesn't even get up
yeah but as as Bessel Van Der kolk says
your body's keeping the score it does
okay so
um
making peace with your past healing from
your past is a has a thought component
to it I can think about this I can think
about the loss I can think about the
near break-in and I'm fine and then
there's another healing part that is
much much much deeper which is my body
doesn't take off on me
my body's at peace too and that's the
level of healing we're looking for here
so
there's one way through it and that's
the practice
and what that might look like is getting
a couple of friends that you trust
and saying
I need to go into your house and walk
around for 15 minutes after dark with
you not there
and I know that sounds crazy and what
you're going to do is you're going to
walk in the front door
and you are going to begin to feel your
body and here's what we're looking to do
create a space a gap they call it you're
going to create a gap between I think
I'm going to die like my body is
starting to react like there's somebody
upstairs and this is all coming down on
me yeah and your Consciousness like no
I'm not I'm okay this is Dan's house
this is Tim's house this is Sue's house
this is you know Laura's apartment
and we're going to practice it and you
are literally going to walk in there and
begin to feel it and it may be that
you're planning on doing this for 15
minutes and you can last three minutes
the first time cool
keep a little log and write it down
and then you're gonna go to a hotel and
you are gonna walk into the hotel and
you're just gonna stop for a second and
feel what your body's doing
and all we're doing is connecting our
thinking and our responding brains we
want our responding brain to know
there's danger oh she's still driving
cool we can turn the alarms off guys she
knows what's up
that's it okay okay and it's just gonna
take some time and by the way I travel
for a living I still don't sleep super
great in hotels I check my sleep with
this whoop strap it lets me know you
didn't get a good night's sleep I just
don't sleep well when I'm not at home
and I've made peace with that that means
if I'm gonna function if I'm gonna get
on stage in front of 5 000 people the
next day I have to have overly ate eaten
right every time I go to a hotel the
first thing I do I don't even unpack no
I unpack I go straight to the gym and I
get my head screwed on straight I get my
body screwed on straight before I do
anything else before I go to soundcheck
before I go do I even fly into towns
early for that reason
because I know the third
um the third component of my Wellness
one is nutrition one is movement and the
other sleep I know I'm not going to get
the Sleep part I just know it and I've
made peace with it I don't fight it I
don't get frustrated anymore I don't go
to war with it
um but that's just the way that's going
to be so you may never totally pass out
in a hotel
but you can you can prop your feet up
and watch TV watch the office and enjoy
life without yeah your body rattling on
you does that make sense
no it does but
like the thought of that I know
it gives me anxiety just thinking about
it it absolutely does absolutely and
again that's your body just trying to
take care of you
because while you've gone off and done
your cute little counseling Elizabeth to
forget all this stuff the body knows we
could get murdered at any second right
and here's this the sucky part you might
you might but probably not
right and maybe but probably not is the
sentence that gets me through everything
it could but probably not maybe right
but probably not there could be it but I
I
all right I'll just be honest with you
when I walk into my friend's house to
feed their dogs at night
my heart starts racing about 200 beats a
minute like I literally think I'm gonna
die
and I have to say no I'm not like I'm
smiling because you and I have a very
similar phobia congratulations we win
um and it just is it just is and I've
made peace with it and now I can go get
my job done I'm never gonna enjoy it I'm
ever gonna love it but I can go get it
get done what I need to get done
okay
okay so what are you going to do next
what's your first first thing you're
gonna do
I guess I'll probably call a friend and
they spend some time in our house I want
you to call three friends
and here's I want you to get weird about
this
okay call three friends and I want you
to see if you can rotate for
um every night for 30 days
just for a few minutes at a time right
start with start with five minutes start
with three minutes
hey Laura this is gonna I'm gonna have
the weirdest thing I have this super
phobia I've never told you about it
freaks me out I'm about to take this new
job I talked to this knucklehead on a
podcast and
um this guy that used to have a real job
and now he's a YouTuber and He suggests
I do this can I borrow your house for
five minutes I just need you to walk
around the yard while I stand in your
house I saw him on Tick Tock it's fine
there you go
um I talked to this Tech talk sensation
and uh I I need to
make a lap upstairs and downstairs in
your home with the lights off for five
minutes
and I do want you to do that whether I
want you to get a flashlight and I want
you to walk into somebody's house and go
up their stairs and go to the end of the
hallway and then come down the stairs
and then walk out and by the way if my
friend did that I would scare the
bejesus out of them I would hide and you
know expect your friends if they're any
friend caliber at all they'll do this
um but we're just gonna teach our bodies
we're all right we can do hard stuff
I'm glad we're not friends John
you know how often I hear that
um but hey uh it's practice practice
practice practice the only true healing
from anxiety is directly through the
middle of it
gotta get connected you gotta show your
body you're not I mean that you're not
in danger that you're safe
you have to show your body that hey I'm
driving and you gotta have other people
you can talk to about this take the
stigma away from it take the shame away
from it take the secrecy away from it
hey I've got this crazy phobia this
wackadophobia I don't like spiders I
have a phobia that every time I see a
snake my body literally wants to vomit
in Diary at the same time it's like
everybody out like everything wants to
leave my body at once and I gotta heal
from that so for 15 minutes can I come
over and you know if you get a boa
constrictor can I just look at it
through a glass and then I'm gonna get
closer I mean closer it's just called
exposure therapy is what it is and if
you can do it safely go for it but I
think you go spend five minutes in your
friend's house then we Turn All the
Lights On you breathe and you go I made
it I made it
and then when you go out to the car sit
in your car for a second and just feel
it I made it
I did it I could do hard stuff and then
tomorrow we're gonna do this again and
then hopefully after 30 days there is a
significant reduction
and act you know
I won't go down the parasympathetic and
sympathetic but your body will stop
taking off on you and you can take this
new job and go make some money and enjoy
your life